[Music]
this song you're gonna perform a castle
on the hill yeah this is about your
neighborhood growing up yeah this is me
basically I'm a recent Springsteen
admirer like I've got into him within
the last three me too
I know yeah yeah we spoke of him yeah
yeah yeah I'm a bit I'm a bit late to
the party but I listen to the river and
I was like I need to write a song like
the river and he inspired you yeah this
is a this is my take on it when I was
six years old broke my leg I was running
from my brother and his friends tasted
sweet perfume of the mountain grass
thrown down I was younger than take me
back to when I
[Music]
broke it he made friends and lost and
through days I've not seen the roaring
fields and so long
go home night-night
[Music]
and it's really
watch the sunset Oh
[Music]
fifteen years old and smoking
hand-rolled cigarettes running from the
law through the back fields and getting
drunk with my friends had my first kiss
on a Friday night I don't reckon that I
did it right but I was younger than take
me back to when we found weekend jobs
and when we got paid we'd buy cheap
spirits and drink them straight me and
my friends have done thumb na been so
long
we broke away
I'm drivin
[Music]
singing to tiny dancer and I miss the
way
[Music]
it's really me watch the sunset
over the car so lonely here we watch the
sunset Oh
[Music]
one friend left so close and one works
down by the coats one not to kiss but
lives alone ones brother overdosed
ones already on his second wife ones
just barely getting by but these people
they raised me and I come way to go home
I still remember these old country names
[Music]
[Applause]
watch the sunset
the car Saloni
Oh
[Music]
watch the sunset over the car so lonely
hill beautiful